STEVE: THE U.S. ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS IS PREPARING TO
CONVERT SOME MIAMI BEACH
CONVENTION CENTER INTO A MEDICAL
FACILITY TO HELP ASSIST IN THE
CV-19 RESPONSE, AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: CURRENTLY, FLORIDA HAS
MORE THAN 14, 700 CONFIRMED
CASES, AND HEALTH OFFICIALS
EXPECT THE PEAK TO HIT THAT
STATE AT THE BEGINNING OF MAY.
BRIAN:  SO JOINING US RIGHT NOW
FROM MIAMI FLORIDA, SENATOR
MARCO RUBIO.
SENATOR I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
ABOUT THIS RESCUE PLAN BECAUSE
YOU FOCUSED ON SMALL BUSINESS,
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
BUT FIRST I WANT TO GET YOUR
SENSE OF FLORIDA.
I SAW THOSE HUGE LINES WHEN IT
COMES TO FOOD BANKS.
HOW IS THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA
RESPONDING TO THE LOCKDOWN?
>> WELL I WANT TO SAY THE
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA HAVE
RESPONDED WELL IN TERMS OF
FOLLOWING THE MANDATES.
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT
TRY TO GET  AROUND IT AND PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TO.
IT’S INTERESTING IF YOU WORK IN
A BLUE COLLAR JOB, YOU’RE
PROBABLY OUT THERE HAVING TO
WORK RIGHT NOW WHETHER YOU WORK
AT THE GROCERY STORE, OR   CVS/
WALGREENS OR  SOME OTHER
PLACE DEEMED ESSENTIAL AND OF
COURSE ALL OF THE PEOPLE, FIRST
RESPONDERS BUT BY AND LARGE
YOU’VE SEEN THAT FLORIDA HAS
OUTPERFORMED ALL OF THE MODELS.
IT’S NOT BECAUSE THE MODELS WERE
WRONG.
IT’S BECAUSE WE ARE DOING OUR
PART, AND WE’RE GOING TO KEEP AN
EYE ON THAT AND I ALSO THINK
OUR LOCAL HOSPITALS ACROSS THE
STATE HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB
OF SORT OF BUILDING UP CAPACITY
AND GETTING READY TO ADDRESS
WHATEVER COMES OUR WAY.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT AND I KNOW
THAT IN THE SENATE, THERE’S
ALREADY SOME TALK ABOUT ANOTHER
PHASE, SOME OF THE POINTS FROM
THE DEMOCRATS NEXT RELIEF BILL
BE A QUARTER OF A TRILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSISTANCE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES, $100 BILLION FOR
HOSPITALS, COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTER, AND HEALTH SYSTEMS,
$150 BILLION FOR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS, AND 15% INCREASE TO
THE MINIMUM SNAP BENEFIT AMONG
OTHER THINGS AND ONE INTERESTING
THING THAT SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER
SUGGESTED, SENATOR, IS FOR UP TO
$25,000 HERO PAY, ESSENTIALLY
FOR THE PEOPLE ON THE FRONTLINES
, WHETHER THEY ARE
NURSES OR  TRUCKERS OR  GROCERY
STORE CLERKS, SOMEHOW, THE
GOVERNMENT COMPENSATING THEM
FOR ESSENTIALLY PUTTING THEIR
LIVES AT RISK EVERY DAY WHEN
THEY GO TO WORK.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT IDEA?
>> WELL THE WAY I THINK WE
SHOULD APPROACH IT IS WE CAN
BIFURCATE THIS INTO TWO PIECES.
THE FIRST IS SORT OF WHAT DO WE
NEED TO DO TO BUILD ON WHAT
WE’VE ALREADY PASSED SO FOR
EXAMPLE,, THE SMALL BUSINESS
FUND, DESPITE SOME EARLY GLITCH
ES, IS ALREADY AT
$66 BILLION, HAVE ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTED SO IT’S MOVING VERY
QUICKLY, IT’S TREMENDOUS DEMAND
SO THAT’S WHY THERE’S GOING TO
BE AN EFFORT TOMORROW TO TRY TO
COME IN AND ADD FUNDS TO THAT SO
BUILDING ON WHAT WE’VE DONE
ADDING TO WHAT WE’VE ALREADY
DONALD PASSED, THE SECOND IS A
RECOVERY BILL, AND THERE’S A
RELIEF AND THEN RECOVERY AND I
THINK FOR A RECOVERY SOME OF
THEM ARE DEEPER MORE SYSTEMIC
REFORMS AND WHAT WE WANT TO SEE
THINGS LIKE INDUSTRIAL
CAPACITY, ON INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL, AND THEN MAYBE SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU’VE
MENTIONED.
LOOK, THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT
THERE EVERY DAY DELIVERING GOODS
, WE’VE HAD A RUN ON PAPER
TOWELS, NOT JUST TOILET PAPER SO
THOSE TRUCKERS MAKING THOSE
LONG-HAULS OVERNIGHT TO
GET NOT JUST PAPER TOWELS BUT
FOOD AND THINGS LIKE THAT INTO
OUR GROCERY STORES NOT TO
MENTION OUR DOCTORS AND NURSES
ARE DOING A PHENOMENON JOB ON
THE FRONTLINE, I’M ALL FOR DOING
POSITIVE THINGS TO HELP THEM
AFTER THIS VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCE.
I THINK THAT OF COURSE IS GOING
TO REQUIRE A LITTLE BIT MORE
THOUGHT AND MAYBE BEING ABLE TO
BRING CONGRESS TOGETHER TO WORK
THROUGH IT SO I’M NOT SAYING NO
TO ANY OF THESE THINGS, I’M JUST
SAYING THOSE THINGS ARE NEW AND
WILL REQUIRE SOME MORE THOUGHT
AND IT’S HARD TO DO THAT RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE WE’RE NOT IN SESSION
, WE DON’T KNOW WHEN WE
WILL BE.
AINSLEY: SENATOR THE PRESIDENT
IS SLAMMING THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION, I’M SURE YOU KNOW
THAT.
HE SAYS THEY’VE BEEN ROUTINELY
WRONG, HE SAID THEY WERE STRONG
LY AGAINST THE TRAVEL BAN
BACK IN JANUARY.
THEY ARE SAYING HE SAYS THAT
EVERYTHING IS POSITIVE TOWARD
CHINA, THEY AREN’T GIVING US THE
RIGHT INFORMATION, AND THAT
THE U.S. IS THE PRIMARY FUNDER
OF THAT ORGANIZATION.
WE GIVE MOST MONEY, BUT YET WE
DON’T GET THE MOST HELP, HE SAYS
SO HE’S TALKING ABOUT CUTTING
FUNDING.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SAYS HE’S
DEFINITELY GOING TO DO WHAT WHAT
DO YOU SAY?
>> A COUPLE OF THINGS LET’S
REMEMBER ON THE FRONTLINE THEY
HAVE PEOPLE ALL OVER THE WORLD
DOING A PHENOMENONAL JOB IN
TERMS OF EPIDEMIOLOGISTS THEY’RE
DOING RESEARCH AND SO FORTH.
OUR PROBLEM IS WITH THE
LEADERSHIP BECAUSE THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION SERVES AN
IMPORTANT PURPOSE.
UNFORTUNATELY, IT HAS BEEN
POLITICIZED.
CHINA HAS UNDERTAKEN AN EFFORT
OVER THE LAST 15 YEARS TO
INFILTRATE AND EXERT INFLUENCE
OVER INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS
AT THE U.N. AND OF COURSE THE
WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION,
AND WHAT YOU SAW EARLY ON IN
THIS PANDEMIC IS THEY WENT TO
CHINA AND CAME OUT SAYING THAT
CHINA IS DOING A GREAT JOB,
EVERYTHING THEY ARE SAYING IS
TRUE, AND THEN CONDEMNING NOT
JUST THE U.S. , BUT ALSO
CONDEMNING ANY COUNTRY THAT
CONSIDERED BANS ON TRAVEL FROM
OR  TO CHINA, AND THERE’S
EVIDENCE THAT ITS BEEN
POLITICIZED THAT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION AT ITS
LEADERSHIP LEVEL HAS POLITICIZED
BY CHINESE INFLUENCE AND CHINESE
AND THAT’S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
THAT ORGANIZATION SHOULD NOT BE
POLITICAL AND SHOULD NOT BE
MAKING PUBLIC HEALTH PRONOUNCE
AMS UNDER DURESS, BUT FROM ANY
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
IT SHOULD BE MAKING THOSE ON THE
BASIS OF MEDICAL SCIENCE,
AND SO I HAVE DEEP CONCERNS
ABOUT IT AND THAT’S WHY I HOPE
THAT AT A MINIMUM WE CAN GET THE
LEADER OF THAT
ORGANIZATION TO RESIGN BECAUSE
HE’S DEFINITELY BEEN POLITICIZED
BRIAN:  SENATOR, EVERY TIME,
EVERY SENTENCE OVER THE LAST FEW
WEEKS WAS UNPRECEDENTED ONE OF
WHICH WAS THE $2.2 TRILLION PLAN
TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR JOBS AND
BUSINESSES THAT AREN’T WORKING
FUNDED.
SO PART OF THE PLAN THAT YOU
HELPED PUT TOGETHER ON SMALL
BUSINESS IN SOME CASES IS NOT
FUNCTIONING YET, NUMBER ONE IS
WHEN THESE PEOPLE COME IN, IF
THEY CAN’T RETAIN THEIR
WORKFORCE AT 75%, THERE WON’T BE
ELIGIBLE TO MAKE THAT LOAN A
GRANT AND IF PEOPLE DON’T COME
BACK IT’S OUT OF THEIR
CONTROL, AND NUMBER TWO IS WHEN
YOU’RE DONE PAYING FOR YOUR
PAYROLL, YOU DON’T HAVE ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY FOR YOUR LEASE, AND
YOUR RENT, SO WOULD YOU BE RE
VISITING SOME OF THAT FOR
THESE HIGHER-PRICED CITIES?
LIKE LOS ANGELES AND NEW YORK
AND MAYBE EVEN MIAMI?
>> YEAH, POTENTIALLY BUT RIGHT
NOW, WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS MORE
JUST TO BE ABLE TO GET THEM OUT
THE DOOR BECAUSE THERE’S BEEN A
VERY STRONG DEMAND FOR A COUPLE
POINTS TO MAKE.
NUMBER ONE, YES, I THINK I FULLY
UNDERSTAND THAT PEOPLE OUT THERE
ARE DESPERATE AND WANT THIS TO
WORK.
SO DO I, AND I ALSO THINK WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOME PERSPECTIVE.
THIS IS A PLAN THAT WAS PASSED
TWO WEEKS AGO THIS FRIDAY,
HASN’T EVEN BEEN TWO WEEKS YET,
IT WAS IMPLEMENTED SIX DAYS
LATER AND UNTIL FRIDAY OF THIS
WEEK THERE WASN’T A BANK IN
AMERICA THAT HAD EVER MADE A PPP
LOAN AND THERE WASN’T AN
FDA HAD NEVER MADE ONE SO
THIS IS A PROGRAM RUSHED OUT IN
SIX DAYS BECAUSE WE ARE IN AN
EMERGENCY.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION IT’S CHAOTIC.
I KNOW THAT FROM LIVING THROUGH
MULTIPLE HURRICANES.
YOU’RE MANAGING THE CHAOS AT THE
SAME TIME AS YOU’RE TRYING TO
GET RID OF THE GLITCHES THAT
APPEAR.
THERE ARE STILL SUBSTANTIAL
OBSTACLES IN THE WAY THAT NEED
TO BE FIXED.
THIS CAN’T BE THE WAY THE
PROGRAM WORKS LONG TERM.
AS FAR AS THE PAYROLL IS
CONCERNED THE POINT OF THE
PROGRAM, THAT’S WHY IT’S
CALLED THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
ACT IS TO GET MONEY INTO THE
HANDS OF SMALL BUSINESS SO
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO PAY THEIR
EMPLOYEES EVEN IF THE BUSINESS
IS NOT OPENING AND RUNNING AND
THERE IS A PORTION OF IT THEY
CAN SPEND ON RENT BUT WE WANTED
THE BULK OF THAT MONEY TO BE TO
MAKE PAYROLL, SO THEY CAN KEEP
PEOPLE OFF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
LINES AND KEEP THEM FROM
DISCONNECTING FROM THEIR
EMPLOYER.
THE GOVERNMENT CAN’T REPLACE ALL
THE REVENUE OF THESE BUSINESSES
AND WE NEVER CLAIMED IT WOULD,
BUT WE DO THINK HELPING KEEP THE
EMPLOYEES ON PAYROLL IS A
BIG ASSISTANCE AND YOU CAN SPEND
A PERCENTAGE.
NOW IF CAN’T HIRE ALL THE PEOPLE
BACK THERE ARE ELEMENTS AT THE
BACK END A YEAR FROM NOW WHERE
YOU CAN SHOW THAT I COULDN’T
HIRE MY PEOPLE BACK BECAUSE THEY
HAD LEFT OR  BECAUSE OF SOME
OTHER IMPEDIMENT AND YOU CAN
HAVE THAT MITIGATED OR
FORGIVEN BUT RIGHT NOW THE
GOAL IS TO KEEP PEOPLE
EMPLOYED AND PUT MONEY IN THE
HANDS OF THE WORKERS.
THAT WAS ALWAYS THE GOAL THAT
WAS AGREED TO ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS.
IT’S NOT PERFECT.
IT CERTAINLY DOESN’T DEAL WITH
EVERY ISSUE BUT IT DEALS WITH A
BIG ONE.
STEVE: SURE.
SENATOR RUBIO, BEFORE YOU GO,
WE’VE ALL BEEN ON LOCKDOWN FOR A
COUPLE OF WEEKS NOW.
WE TRIED TO SAVE A DAY OF THE
WEEK AS OFTEN AS WE CAN
BECAUSE ALL THE DAYS ARE KIND OF
BLENDING INTO EACH OTHER.
WE SAW THE NEWS THIS MORNING
THAT APPARENTLY YOUR COLLEAGUE,
RAND PAUL, IS FULLY RECOVERED
FROM COVID AND NOW HE IS
VOLUNTEERING AT HIS LOCAL
HOSPITAL BECAUSE HE IS A DOCTOR.
JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY, IN YOUR
CASE, WHAT IS A SITTING MEMBER
OF THE U.S. SENATE DO DURING A
LOCKDOWN?
WHAT’S YOUR DAY LIKE?
>> WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME
TELL YOU THEORETICALLY BOTH RAND
PAUL AND MY FRIEND THAT’S A
CONGRESSMAN HERE ALSO INFECTED
THEORETICALLY ANYWAYS THE
ASSUMPTION IS THAT THEY HAVE
SOME IMMUNITY, THAT BECAUSE THEY
ACQUIRED THE VIRUS SO THAT’S I
DON’T WANT TO GO THROUGH WHAT
THEY’VE GONE THROUGH, ESPECIALLY
MARIO, BUT SO THAT’S A BENEFIT
FOR THEM AND IT’S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD THINK ABOUT IN TERMS OF
THAT NEW TEST COMING ON BOARD TO
SHOW THAT PEOPLE HAVE SUFFICIENT
ANTIBODIES BUT OUR BASIC DAY
STARTS EARLY WITH SOME MEDIA
HITS BEINGS AND THEN I SPEND ALL
DAY PROBABLY EIGHT TO 10 HOURS A
DAY EITHER DOING A SERIES OF
CONFERENCE CALLS OR  WEBINARS
WITH DIFFERENT GROUPS IN FLORIDA
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
YESTERDAY I TALKED TO THE
FLORIDA BANKERS, THE NATIONAL
BANKERS ASSOCIATION, AND THEN A
LOT OF PHONE CALLS WITH FOLKS IN
THE ADMINISTRATION, I’LL BE
SPEAKING TO THE FDIC TODAY ABOUT
THE PROGRAM, SECRETARY MNUCHIN
HAS BEEN PHENOMENON AND
ACCESSIBLE AND VERY RESPONSIVE,
SO REALLY, THE FOCUS OF MY DAY
HAS BEEN LARGELY ON THE PROGRAM,
AND GETTING IT TO WORK,
IDENTIFYING THE IMPEDIMENTS AND
TRYING TO DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN
FROM HOME USING THE PHONE, USING
THIS COMPUTER AND COMMUNICATING
TO THE PUBLIC AS WELL, SO THAT’S
BEEN THE GIST OF OUR EXISTENCE
HERE SINCE WE GOT BACK FROM D.C.
AND THERE’S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONALD THEN TRYING TO STAY SAFE.
TRYING TO MODEL THE BEHAVIOR
THAT WE’RE ASKING OTHERS TO
FOLLOW WHETHER IT’S WEARING A
MASK IN PUBLIC.
I DON’T LOOK GOOD IN A MASK BUT
I HAVE ONE HERE THAT WE MADE SO
I’VE BEEN USING THAT, AND ALSO,
YOU KNOW, STAYING AT HOME AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND WORKING
FROM HERE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
SO BEEN QUITE BUSY ACTUALLY, BUT
I THINK WE ALL LIKE TO SEE LIFE
GET BACK TO NORMAL AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT WE GOT TO GET
THROUGH THIS.